c'était il ya 70 ans jour pour jour
l'armée soviétique est libéré le camp
d'auschwitz et birkenau un camp dans
lequel plus d'un million de déportés
trouvèrent la mort bonjour à tous
édition spéciale sur les chaînes
parlementaires pour cette journée
d'hommage et avant de se rendre à
auschwitz le président de la république
françois hollande et ce matin au
mémorial de la shoah pour commencer
cette journée de commémoration
officielle françois hollande qui se
trouve au mémorial depuis une heure
maintenant et qui prononcera dans
quelques minutes un discours discours
que vous pourrez bien sûr suivre en
direct sur les chaînes parlementaires
vous le voyez sur ces images françois
hollande qui vient tout juste de
s'entretenir avec des survivants du camp
d'auschwitz mais aussi des jeunes élèves
françois hollande qui va maintenant
visiter une exposition avant de
prononcer ce discours et pour commenter
ce discours avec moi il parlait de cette
journée de commémoration quatre invités
deux parlementaires corinne bouchoux
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice europe
ecologie les verts de maine et loire
vous êtes également historienne philippe
gosselin bonjour des bouquets de la
manche également maître de conférences à
sciences po iannis roder r bonjour
professeur d'histoire-géographie vous
êtes formateur au mémorial de la shoah
et notre chroniqueur politique qu'est
michael szames s bonjour alors on l'a
dit à françois hollande qui va
s'exprimer dans quelques minutes quelle
va être la teneur du discours du
président la république il y aura une
dimension fonctionnement historique d'un
rappel des faits d'une remise en place
de la dimension historique bien
évidemment de l'horreur de ce qui s'est
passé dans ces camps il y aura
évidemment un contexte contexte actuel
avec ce qui s'est passé en france
évidemment et ce besoin d'unité
nationale et puis il y aura quelques
annonces certainement par le président
de la république et notamment sur le
renforcement de l'arsenal juridique
contre le racisme et contre
l'antisémitisme cessons cette
circonstance aggravante contre le
racisme c'est un renforcement de
l'arsenal juridique qui a été mise en
place déjà par christiane taubira et qui
sera en clair pour être très concret
renforcé quand il ya une agression un
harcèlement une atteinte au bien et
qu'il s'agit d'un acte raciste ou
antisémite et bien les sanctions seront
aggravées il y aura également
certainement un échelon supérieur sur
internet vous savez sur ce qu'on appelle
cette théorie du complot ou ce qu'on
appelle sur les sites qui hébergent des
propagandes de thèses négationnistes il
ya aussi du renforcement des sanctions
et puis renforcement par contre à
l'école ça déjà été annoncée la semaine
dernière par najat vallaud belkacem est
annoncée encore une fois un certainement
par le président de la république pour
aider les professeurs à expliquer ce qui
s'est passé il ya 70 ans alors corinne
bouchoux un françois hollande avait
prévu de longue date de se rendre cet
après midi à auschwitz mais il a rajouté
cette étape ce matin au mémorial de la
shoah il a tenu à rendre hommage
soixante quinze mille juifs de france
qui ont été déportés c'est un discours
qui intervient dans un contexte
particulier en contexte de fortes
inquiétudes pour la communauté juive de
france mais écoutez je ne peux pas
commenter par anticipation un discours
dont je ne connais pas la teneur ce que
l'on peut dire c'est qu'il y a une
grande attente il ya besoin à la fois de
rassurer mais il ya aussi besoin
d'expliquer vous l'avez dit sûrement de
punir mais je dirais surtout de prévenir
et c'est là où le rôle du savoir et des
enseignants est fondamentale
philippe gosselin c'était important
cette étape supplémentaire de rajouter
ce discours de rendre hommage
particulièrement
oui je crois que c'est effectivement
important il faut aussi rappeler que des
juifs de france ont été déportés c'est
important plus de soixante-dix mille
premiers points et puis nous sommes
aussi dans un contexte très particulier
bien sûr celui des attentats du 7
janvier mais avant même les attentats
beaucoup de familles juives qui se
posent la question de leur départ vers
israël ce qui pose évidemment un certain
nombre de questions sur leur bien-être
dans notre pays sur la perception
qu'elles ont ces familles
de la proche française de notre histoire
donc je crois que oui c'est évidemment
un élément très important et qui est
attendue bien sûr et gagnez trop
d'heures dans le contexte actuel c'est
important d'avoir comme ça un discours
du président de la république qui
souhaite rappeler le sens de l'histoire
et transmettre ce qu'il s'est passé oui
je pense que le symbole est important
est le fait que le président de la
république aille au mémorial de la shoah
et là nous le voyons dans la salle des
fichiers ces fichiers qui ont servi aux
arrestations des gens notamment lors des
rafles de l'été 1900 1949 c'est très
important parce que symboliquement la
république marque son attachement à
cette histoire a fait sienne cette
histoire et puisque vous parlez de
l'actualité je crois que pour les juifs
de france c'est un geste qui compte
voilà donc il est dans la salle des
fichiers il faut savoir que ces fichiers
sont propriétés de la république
française ils sont propriétés archives
nationales mais ils sont entreposés au
mémorial de la shoah ces fichiers ce
sont plusieurs fichiers notamment les
les fichiers des camps de drancy de
pithiviers de beaune la rolande mais
aussi copie de la préfecture de la pp à
la préfecture de police de paris ces
fiches qui ont servi dans les
arrestations dans les arrestations et
comme je le disais notamment à l'été
1942 quand on remettait ses fiches aux
policiers avec l'adresse le nom et c'est
qui qui permettait d'aller arrêter les
gens ces fichiers ont été dressées après
l'ordonance allemandes du 27 septembre
1940 qui demandait à ce que les juifs
soient recensés alors je vous le disais
avant de
deux regards de regarder un
de prononcer ce discours françois
hollande a tenu à rencontrer des
survivants cette journée il a tenu à
mettre en avant à ces survivants et
surtout des jeunes une rencontre entre
les survivants et les jeunes puisque est
la transmission ce sera le maître mot de
cette journée je vous propose de
regarder un extrait de ce qu'il s'est
passé je ne sais pas si on peut le
regarder alors peut-être pas il n'est
pas encore prêt c'était il ya quelques
minutes françois hollande qui
assistaient à cette rencontre entre des
jeunes et des survivants mais avant cela
on va regarder ce qu'il s'est passé il
ya maintenant 70 ans jour pour jour la
libération de ce camp d'auschwitz on va
parler de ce qu'était aux chutes mais
avant cela regardez ces images datant de
la libération du camp
le destin de ces hommes a croisé la
grande histoire auschwitz à commencer
par josef plachy ski ce polonais a été
au contact d'un des architectes de la
machine de mort nazi rudolf hausse ce
simple prisonniers étaient le coiffeur
de l'impitoyable commandant du camp
régulièrement ciseaux en main ils se
retrouvaient dans la même pièce que son
bourreau l'idée de le tuer lui a
traversé l'esprit mais les représailles
aurait été désastreuse
on pose souvent cette question j'étais
conscient des conséquences je n'étais
pas fou si je lui trancher la gorge etc
l'icwa
la moitié des prisonniers du camp
étaient aussitôt exécuté la moitié mais
c'est vrai personne n'a jamais été aussi
près de ce que moi
les images de mort ont encore
aujourd'hui les rescapés et ceux qui ont
découvert auschwitz ce soldat de l'armée
rouge a participé à la libération du
camp il ne soupçonnait pas le degré
d'horreur
où quelque sorte c'était presque
agréable pour nous on avait compris
qu'on avait fait quelque chose de bien
qu'on avait libéré et sauver ces gens de
l'enfer bien qu'à ce moment là on avait
encore aucune idée de quel camp il
s'agissait
qui lui n'a pas attendu les soldats pour
reprendre sa liberté ce polonais fait
partie des cent quarante quatre
prisonniers à avoir réussi à s'évader il
s'est échappé par une glaciale midi vers
où le thermomètre affiche et -10° riche
mais nous nous sommes déshabiller nous
traversions la ceux-là et au milieu de
la rivière j'ai entendu la sirène à ce
moment là je me suis rendu compte de
toute la situation j'ai eu l'impression
que tout ce que j'avais vécu appartenait
à un autre monde et que je venais me
rêvais d'un régime ans
les rescapés qui ont survécu ont
aujourd'hui plus de 85 ans il continue à
parler pour que personne n'oublie ce
cauchemar
voilà pour ce sujet est signée mounir
ceci alors je le disais un pianiste
robert la commémoration du 70e
anniversaire se fera autour des
survivants
oui bien sûr le temps avance et
malheureusement les survivants
disparaissent les plus jeunes ont
aujourd'hui autour de 85 ans ça veut
dire qu'ils avaient à peu près 14 ans 15
ans au moment où ils sont arrivés à
auschwitz c'est sûr que cette parole à
un moment voilà quand elle disparaîtra
va va nous manquer mais c'est là où le
travail de l'historien est extrêmement
important où le travail d'histoire ce
fait vous savez
on a beaucoup parlé des témoins de la
première guerre mondiale et on m'a dit
comment nous ferons quand ils ne seront
plus là écoutez on a fait de l'histoire
eh bien je crois que pour l'histoire de
la shoah nous ferons pareil nous ferons
de l'histoire
exactement nous sommes vraiment à ce
moment charnière je vois là je ne
préjuge pas de ce qui va se passer dans
les prochaines années mais évidemment
toute vie a une fin et donc nos amis des
portes et ancien déporté un jour
disparaîtront et ce sera aux historiens
de faire le travail qu'ils ont déjà
largement entamé
le directeur du site elle a dit ce sera
le dernier anniversaire ont célébré avec
un groupe important de survivants
c'était important aujourd'hui de les
mettre à l'honneur oui c'était
évidemment important parce qu'il faut
replacer tout cela dans un ensemble ces
2 70e
sert du débarquement de normandie de
provence et la reconquête c'est la
bataille de france c'est la libération
des camps et puis c'est après le 8 mai
1945 donc c'est aussi un environnement
mémorielle qui qui est important et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui 27 janvier 70
ans après prend un sens encore une fois
tout à fait particulier compte tenu des
événements contemporains savez on a dix
sept étaient en normandie notamment
provence que la paix était fragile mais
que nous avions cette chance
extraordinaire de vivre dans une europe
en paix dans un pays en paix il ya je
crois que ce qui s'est passé début
janvier nous rappelle la grande
fragilité de nos démocraties et donc il
est important important de rappeler
aussi toutes les horreurs qui ont pu se
se dérouler et je crois que le maximum
de témoins possibles seront bien
présents aujourd'hui peut-être pour le
75e encore quelques-uns effectivement le
temps des témoins peu à peu
pas ce sont des passeurs ils passent
leurs témoignages à à l'histoire mais ce
qui importe c'est que leur témoignage
immédiat premier soit soit bien là et et
qu'on puisse se les approprier je crois
à chacun et chacune d'entre nous c'est
pour ça que je me réjouis aussi de voir
qu'une séquence particulière en
direction des jeunes se sont évidemment
vers eux que l'on doit ce se tourner
vers ce que l'on doit avoir une action
très très privilégié en n'oubliant pas
aussi qu'on veut derrière chaque jeune
ya des parents et c'est l'occasion
indirectement je dire un peu
trivialement mais de remettre une petite
couche parce qu'encore une fois tout
cela paraît bien lointain et on a aussi
aujourd'hui une théorie du complot on le
voit d'ailleurs sur d'autres sujets qui
qui fait florès donc il faut rappeler
aux beach c'est plus d'un million de
personnes qui qui ont disparu dont des
français c'est une espèce de
rationalisation de de la mort il faut
aussi le rappeler ce gazage n'est pas
une invention cette concentration n'est
pas une invention donc il ya cette force
effectivement des témoins et même si par
la force des choses ils sont moins
nombreux aujourd'hui que pour le 60e et
est plus que pour le 75e ils ont encore
7,7 valeur extraordinaire du du
témoignage et du respect qu'on leur doit
très sincèrement corinne bouchoux un
célèbre aujourd'hui les 70 ans de la
libération d'auschwitz
pourquoi ce camp polonais d'auschwitz
est maintenant devenue le symbole de la
shoah le symbole des camps de
concentration
écoutez là j'avoue que l'émotion
m'étreint
entre l'événement et discours du
président de la république je j'avoue ma
difficulté à vous faire un cours
d'histoire je vous me pardonnerez je
vais pas répondre à votre question mais
je voudrais dire puisqu'on est avant le
discours du président la république que
je pense que c'est très symbolique et
sûrement historique et je voudrais faire
le lien historique aussi avec la
déclaration qui avait fait en 1995 le
président chirac qui avait rappelé quand
même que tout ce que nous
commémorons aujourd'hui n'a été possible
aussi que parce qu'en france il y à une
partie de la population qui sous
diverses formes ya collaboré et donc je
pense que c'est important que à la fois
on est ce cette célébration mais qu'on
n'oublie pas aussi je dirais que tout ça
a été rendue possible aussi parce que il
y a eu un appareil politique un appareil
administratif et très concrètement des
personnes
qui ont participé à des portes et des
personnes qui se sont ensuite retrouvés
ensuite je pense que c'est surtout ça
que que m'inspire cette commémoration
est l'image que nous découvrons du
président qui sur le point de prononcer
son discours mais qu'est ce ça a été un
tournant cet espoir de jacques chirac en
oui parce que jusque-là on n'osait pas
dire vraiment les choses on se rappelle
de françois mitterrand et de ce qu'il y
avait à appliquer sur
tout ce côté obscur de françois
mitterrand à l'époque des de ces
relations et jacques chirac finalement a
fendu l'armure quelque part de ce que
les français attendaient la communauté
juive également qui attendait énormément
de ce discours et enfin la libération de
la parole a été annoncée à
oradour-sur-glane lors d'un discours
vraiment très fort à l'époque du
président de la république ce n'était
pas vraiment attendu ce discours à
l'époque en 1995 on n'attendait pas
jacques chirac à cette occasion et ça ça
a beaucoup changé aussi la façon dont
les français ont regardé le président de
la république et on regarde l histoire
de la france à partir de là quelque
chose s'est ouvert la parole aussi s'est
ouverte et finalement le dialogue avec
la communauté juive de l'époque était
assez compliqué et à partir de ceux de
ce discours le rapprochement entre les
communautés juive et les représentants
de la politique française il ya vraiment
eu un rapprochement qui s'est créée puis
après eva discours aussi à l'époque de
nicolas sarkozy où il avait créé une
certaine polémique parce qu'il avait dit
que l'europe était aussi responsable de
ce qui s'était passé
à auschwitz et ailleurs dans les autres
quand ça eu
différentes polémiques et se sont créés
à cette époque là donc on attend ce que
françois hollande va pouvoir dire
aujourd'hui même si en 2012 il a déjà
annoncé quelques secondes quelques
grands événements il va notamment été un
dialogue assez fort aussi envers la
communauté juive ce sera certainement
quelque chose d'historique forcément 70
ans d'histoire c'est évident mais il y
aura quelque chose d'un message
aujourd'hui qui est attendu par la
communauté juive qu'il est vraiment
vraiment en danger vous le rappeler tout
à l'heure que cela les actes antisémites
en france n'ont jamais été aussi
importants 851 en 2014 ils ont une
humble c'est le doute par rapport à 2007
1 c'est le crif et le conseil
représentation des institutions juives
de france mais aussi source et par le
ministère de l'intérieur ce sont des
chiffres qui est assez crédible
évidemment la communauté vit aujourd'hui
à pearl à la une du monde il ya encore
quelques jours où vous voyez ces juifs
qui vont quitter la france donc la
communauté juive attend un signe très
fort d'autant qu' on vous rappelle
évidemment des actes qui ont lieu à
l'hyper cacher et de ces attentats
aujourd'hui les français juifs qui
vivent en france
attendre un signal très fort de la part
de françois hollande c'est certainement
ce qu'il va donner aujourd'hui dans son
discours discours a un qui devrait avoir
lieu dans quelques minutes cette
actuelle mme eric de rothschild le
président du mémorial de la shoah qui
est en train de s'exprimer françois
hollande qu'il devrait prendre la parole
on le disait dans quelques minutes alors
yanis moder je vais revenir à ce qui
était au chevet de la question je
faisais tout à l'heure à corinne
bouchoux
c'est vrai que pendant un certain temps
bücken valdes a été le symbole d'un des
camps de concentration puisque c'est là
que beaucoup de français de juifs
français ont été déportés et aujourd'hui
dans la mémoire collective c'est
auschwitz qui est devenu ce symbole de
la choix pourquoi en réalité les juifs
français n'ont pas été et déporté à
buchenwald mais bien à auschwitz est en
fait le basculement qui se fait entre
buchenwald et à auschwitz et le
basculement de la déportation qu'on va
appeler très vite politique à la
déportation pour reprendre des termes
des termes de l'époque raciale c'est à
dire déportation concernant les juifs et
c'est une question c'est vraiment un
cheminement de la mémoire nationale si
vous voulez et ce basculement qui se
fait dans les années soixante dix ans à
peu près et concomitants aussi et bien
deux et bien de la montée de 7 de cette
mémoire juive de l'apparition aussi le
négationnisme de de ski de du livre
également très important de l'américain
de robert paxton qui a aussi permis
d'écrire cette histoire de la
collaboration dont vous avez devant vous
avez fort justement parler la sortie du
film shoah en 1985 d'eau dans ce monde
qui est un événement tout cela si vous
voulez participe de l'émergence de la
mémoire de la déportation des juifs à
ceci près que vous partez vous parlais
tout à l'heure des 75 mille juifs
déportés oui mais ce ne sont pas 75
mille victimes juives ce sont 80 mille
victimes juives de la shoah en france
puisque on a tendance à oublier
l'essentiel ils ont un petit peu la
déportation tous et toutes ses enfants
toutes ces femmes tous ces hommes qui
sont morts dans les camps d'internement
français internés parce que juif ou qui
ont été fusillés lors de cet épisode
qu'on pourrait qualifier de guerre
civile en 1900 1944 ou alors dans le
cadre de la politique des otages donc
tout ça fait que à peu près le bilan
aujourd'hui autour de 80 me personnes
assassinées dans le cadre de cette
politique que les nazis appelait la
politique de la solution finale donc
cette émergence de la mémoire a propulsé
auschwitz premier plan si vous voulez de
la mémoire de la déportation d'une
manière générale mais c'est le cas
partout en europe parce que je suis
c'était vraiment le coeur d'un de la
déportation de ce processus politique de
la déportation des juifs d'une grande
partie de l'europe et notamment des
juifs des balkans et d'europe de l'ouest
et puis c'est aussi à la fois c'est ce
qui met un petit peu toutes les
politiques nazi auschwitz était à la
fois en camp de concentration un camp
d'extermination ça aussi c c'est toute
la difficulté si vous voulez c'est à
dire que l'espace le plus complexe est
devenu le paradigme est devenu celui qui
voilà qui est devenue le symbole de la
déportation notamment de la shoah et
c'est être extrêmement compliqué parce
que comme vous venez de le dire sur eux
mêmes espaces se mêle différentes
politiques qui n'ont pas les mêmes buts
et donc nécessairement différentes
populations et tout cela est mêlé et
cela rend extrêmement compliqué la
lisibilité des politiques et la
lisibilité du site
vous le disiez 1 vous parler de ces
années 60 70 il faut le dire qu'avant il
y avait une chape de plomb en france sur
ce qu'était la shoah on en parlait très
peu la découverte de la shoah s'est fait
à partir de ces années là oui enfin on
en a parlé si vous voulez mais c'était
on était dans une période
ou
la suite de ce que désiraient général de
go de perdre de réconciliation nationale
1942 144 un véritable traumatisme
il fallait reconstituer reconstruire la
nation française l'unifier et donc
effectivement
la collaboration de l'administration
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure fort
justement
à était une tâche et cela il fallait un
petit peu l'oublier on va écouter en
direct le discours de françois hollande
qui prend la parole au mémorial de la
shoah je suis le président de
l'assemblée nationale mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
madame la maire de paris mesdames
messieurs les ambassadeurs
monsieur le président du mémorial
mesdames messieurs les anciens déportés
le 27 janvier
est une date à jamais gravé dans la
mémoire de l'humanité
il y à 70 ans
le 27 janvier 1945
vers 15h
les armées soviétiques ouvre les portes
du camp d'auschwitz birkenau
c'était la révélation de l'horreur
ce n'est pas encore une libération
car la plupart des survivants avaient
été emmenés par les nazis dans une
longue marche
la marche de la mort
épuisés de faim de froid de maladie ils
vivaient leurs derniers martyrs dans les
plaines glacées de silésie
ainsi les grossman avait pu écrire dans
son enfer n'avait rien vu de si atroce
vous vous l'avez vécu
le monde lui découvrait
l'extermination méthodique
programme et
scientifiques des juifs
un crime qui n'avait pas de nom
tellement il était ignoble alors un
nouveau mot fut créée pour le désigner
la shoah
le plus grand crime jamais connu et
jamais commis dans l'humanité il fut
perpétré
en terre d'europe
par le régime d'une des nations les plus
civilisés de notre continent
et il trouva des alliés des complices
jusqu'ici en france sous le gouvernement
de vichy
ce crime fut est unique par son ampleur
6 millions de femmes et d'hommes
exterminés parce que juifs
et combien d'autres mis en esclavage
mise à mort parce que s'ils gagnent
mot sexuelle slave communiste résistants
handicapés
6 millions
parmi lesquels un million et demi
d'enfants
trois quarts des juifs d'europe plus du
tiers de la population juive dans le
monde
ce crime fut unique par sa méthode
bureaucratique
industriels
les nazis avaient fait de la solution
finale comme il l'appelait un problème
qu'il leur fallait régler par tous
moyens
d'abord dressé des listes
avec des millions de noms
pour que l'on sache qui était les juifs
comment les retrouver
et pourtant laissé aucun de côté
puis
les nazis sont allés pas tout seul
d'ailleurs
les chercher
les ont raflé
embarquez
entassés dans des wagons à bestiaux
puis les ont conduits vers les chambres
à gaz
voilà ce qui s'est passé en plein 20e
siècle voilà ce qui fût
ce crime fut unique aussi par sa nature
il s'agissait de détruire les preuves
que l'assassinât était été commis par
balles comme en ukraine
par camion à gaz comme un chêne l'eau ou
dans des camps d'extermination
comme à auch witz
les mêmes précautions fut reprise par
les nazis il s'agissait de maquiller
l'horreur
pour qu'elle soit menée jusqu'à son
terme pour qu'elle soit définitive tous
les juifs
devaient mourir
il ne devait plus rien rester de leur
présence
les cadavres étaient brûlés comme au
moyen âge lors des grandes épidémies
les cendres dispersées pour qu'il ne
reste aucune trace de l'abomination
il s'agissait d' exclure les juifs de la
société des humains pour les faire
disparaître du passé du présent
et de l'avenir
et pour que soit rendu
impossible le travail de deuil pour les
éventuels survivants
robert badinter et voit que l' attente
désespérée du retour de son père
et l'absence de résignation à sa
disparition
bruno bettelheim ajoute
que pour lui le deuil fut impossible
puisque certains sont revenus pourquoi
mes parents à moi
ne reviendrait-il pas un jour telle
était sa question
ils ne sont jamais revenus
mais ici au mémorial de la shoah leur
nom figure pour toujours
ils n'étaient plus que cendres et fumées
ils retrouvent grâce à vous une place
dans l'éternité de la pierre et vous
mesdames et messieurs
vous vous êtes les derniers témoins
infatigable
inconsolable
intraitable et vous continuez de nous
dire ce qui fût il y à 70 ans je veux
ici vous exprimer toute ma
reconnaissance
toute la gratitude de la nation
pour
le travail le mot est mal choisi pour le
devoir que vous vous êtes infligé un de
plus pour témoigner pour dire pour
raconter vous parcourez les villes et
les écoles de france
vous fait même encore et j'imagine
ce que ça représente comme souffrances
le voyage vers auch wyss sur les lieux
mêmes où vous fûtes déportés vous voulez
montrer l'enfer à ceux qui ignorent
qu'il a existé sur cette terre et que
vous l'avez connu
c'est simone veil qui dit que les
déportés ne sont jamais sortis des camps
que leurs esprits y est resté et que la
shoah continue de hanter leurs vies
et leurs nuits alors vous avez décidé de
faire de votre cauchemar une leçon
une leçon pour les autres vous êtes le
visage de l'humanité
le beau visage
celle que
les bourreaux voulait supplicié cette
humanité et c'est pourquoi
les corps de votre voix ne doit pas
faiblir
parce que sinon comme le disait et loire
périront
je sais ce qui vous tourmentent
qui parlera
des cornes qui parlera de la shoah quand
vous ne serez plus là
je vous fait cette promesse qui est un
engagement la république française
n'oubliera jamais et avec les documents
les témoignages que vous nous laissez
les livres les textes les
enregistrements et ce lieu qui est le
vôtre alors nous n'oublierons jamais
le mémorial de la chia monsieur le
président est issu du centre de
documentation juive contemporaine dont
la création à grenoble dans la
clandestinité en avril 43 fut en tant
que tel un acte de résistance
isaksson son fondateur avait décidé en
pleine occupation de rassembler les
premières archives de ce qu'ont signé
les écrits
d'accumuler des preuves pour qu'un jour
la souffrance se transforme en mémoire
puis la mémoire en histoire en 1956 le
centre s'installent ici dans le marais
ce quartier du coeur de paris
qui avait été pour les juifs du début du
siècle un refuge
avant de devenir dans les années 40 un
piège là où
on est allé vous cherchez il ya 70 ans
le
pire a été commis il fallait donc qu'il
y ait un mémorial
le 25 janvier 2005 le président jacques
chirac l'inaugurer avec ce mur dédié aux
75 mille 721 juifs qui furent déportés
de france avec la complicité active de
l'état français il avait commencé son
discours jacques chirac par ces mots
tirés de la bible hébraïque
souviens toi
n'oublie jamais
le 21 septembre 2012 j'ai moi même
inauguré le mémorial de la shoah de 36
36 cette ville dont d'où partaient les
trains vers auschwitz
j'étais entouré de jeunes venus des
écoles de la seine saint denis à qui
j'ai lancé le même appel ne jamais
oublier
car ce serait insulter ceux qui sont
morts dans les camps
aujourd'hui le mémorial et je veux
féliciter toute l'équipe
a pu rassembler 40 millions de documents
accueille deux cent mille visiteurs
chaque année
et organisé d'ailleurs une fois par an à
l'occasion de yom hashoah la cérémonie
de lecture publique des noms de tous les
déportés juifs français
cette cérémonie dure 24 heures
et en 24 heures il n'est pas possible de
lire même la moitié des noms de ces
innocents supplicié le mémorial est
dédiée à la transmission
c'est à dire un lieu où
il est expliqué autant qu'il est
possible analyse et autant que
nécessaire le mal et le poursuivre même
ce mal dans ses moindres replis
le mémorial c'est un lieu de vigilance
de clairvoyance où on apprend que la
mémoire est un engagement
un engagement contre toutes les haines
car le mémorial
commémore la shoah mais aussi tous les
génocides
le 20e anniversaire du génocide des
tutsi au rwanda
et cette année il célébrera
l'anniversaire du génocide des arméniens
ce mémorial porte la douleur la vôtre
celle des survivants mais elle porte
aussi la responsabilité des vivants il
exige donc le mémorial le dépassement
pour conjurer l'effacement d'effacement
qui serait le dernier crime
des baux
avec cette interrogation terrible qui
nous étreint encore aujourd'hui
comment après la shoah
comme ans après
ce crime contre l'humanité cette
ignominie qui poussent à la haine
raciste de certains jusqu'à
l'extermination de leurs semblables
comment l'antisémitisme peut-il encore
ressurgir telle est la question qui nous
est une fois encore posée pourquoi les
juifs ont ils le sentiment que jamais
ils n'auront de repos ni de répit
peggy écrivait c'était 40 ans avant la
shoah
depuis cinq ans tchèques les juifs
vivent trempé dans la douleur
ils vivent encore aujourd'hui dans la
douleur
et j'entends l'appel de ceux qui me
demandent nos demandes quand cette
malédiction finira
il y a trois semaines à paris
quatre hommes sont morts dans un magasin
casher
pour le même motif
qu ont été raflés les familles du vel
d'hiv en 1942
qui ont été frappés les fidèles de la
rue copernic en 1980 qui ont été
assassinés les promeneurs de la rue des
rosiers en 1982 qui a été torturé le
jeune ilan halimi en 2006 a été massacré
les enfants de l'école aux as tu auras
de toulouse en 2012 parce qu'ils étaient
juifs
ils sont morts non pour ce qu'ils
avaient fait
mais pour ce qu'ils étaient des juifs
et ils sont encore quatre noms qui
doivent s'ajouter à ceux si nombreux
inscrits sur ce mur de la mémoire
la montée des actes antisémites et
depuis plusieurs années une réalité
insupportable
leur nombre aurait doublé l'année
dernière
agression
incivilités
vandalisme
ce fléau conduis je le sais
certains juifs à s'interroger sur leur
présence en france
la france à laquelle ils ont donné tout
leur coeur
et dont ils ont ressenti profondément au
cours de leur vie
les joies et les tristesses
cette france qui les aime
comme elle aime tous les enfants de la
république
mais cette france où parfois ils ne se
sentent plus en sécurité
et ce doute cette interrogation est une
blessure
une blessure terrible pour la république
qu'elle doit soigner qu'elle doit
traiter
vous français de confession juive
votre place est ici chez vous
la france est votre patrie vous lui avez
donné votre talent
votre travail
votre courage et parfois votre saut
notre pays ne serait plus la france s'il
devait vivre sans vous
et si le terrorisme vous conduisez à
vous éloigner de la terre de france
de la langue française de la culture
française de la république française qui
émancipe et les juifs alors le
terrorisme aurait atteint son but
la responsabilité des autorités de la
république
elles sont ici présentes tout rassembler
et donc de tout faire pour que les juifs
soient pleinement chez eux en france
pour que jamais il n'y s'y sentent
menacés ou isolées
pour combattre un ennemi
il faut d'abord le connaître et le
nommer
l'antisémitisme il a changé de visage
il n'a pas perdu ses racines millénaires
certains de ces ressorts n'ont pas
changé hélas dans la nuit des temps
c'est toujours le complot le soupçon la
falsification
mais aujourd'hui il se nourrit aussi de
la haine d'israël
il importe les conflits du moyen-orient
il établit de façon abjecte
la con culpabilité des juifs dans le
malheur des peuples il entretient les
théories du complot qui se diffusent
sans limite théorie du complot qui ont
dans le passé
conduit déjà au pire
alors face à ces menaces
il nous faut des réponses des réponses
fortes des réponses adaptées
la première c'est la sécurité
le gouvernement de manuel valls a pris
les dispositions qui convenait pour que
les synagogues les commerces les écoles
les centres culturels de la communauté
juive soient protégés il ya même eu une
présence de militaires pour assurer
cette protection
je sais aussi l'amertume et la colère
que cette présence inspire à beaucoup
d'entre vous comment en 2015
comment accepter qu'il faille des
soldats en armes pour défendre les juifs
de france
c'est nécessaire et nous le faisons et
nous le ferons aussi longtemps que ce
sera demandée je veux aller plus loin en
améliorant la visibilité et l'efficacité
des sanctions
ce qui supposera de généraliser la
caractérisation racistes et antisémites
comme circonstance aggravante d'un délit
et sortir la répression de la parole
raciste et anti sémitisme du droit de la
presse pour l'intégrer au droit pénal
général et pour que la sanction soit
l'occasion d'une prise de conscience
des peines
alternatives à valeur pédagogique
exemplaires seront prononcées
la deuxième réponse c'est la
transmission c'est la connaissance
c'est le rôle de l'école
je veux redire ma confiance à l'égard
des professeurs des enseignants de notre
pays il faut leur travail
nous devrons les aider à le mener à bien
et partager avec eux pour les traiter
les inquiétudes qui leur inspire que
leur inspirent les événements récents
comment des élèves ont-ils pu le 9
janvier dernier briser l'unité du
recueillement c'est une nouvelle alerte
parmi d'autres elle nous oblige l'un des
instruments pour désamorcer cette
ignorance c'est l'enseignement de
l'histoire de la shoah elle est au
programme de l'école du cm2 de la
troisième de la première elle doit
pouvoir être enseigner sans aucune
restriction
il ya aussi un certain nombre
d'événements qu'il nous faut renouveler
le concours national de la résistance et
de la déportation dont je remettrai les
prix le 8 mai prochain à l'occasion des
cérémonies du 70e anniversaire de la
défaite du nazisme
ce prix
ce concours existe depuis 1961 il doit
être
renouvelée rénové
je souhaite qu'il puisse y avoir une
mission qu'ils soient conduites pour en
assurer la pérennité
le mémorial doit prendre aussi tout
sympa
il accueille près de 2000 groupe
d'élèves du primaire du collège et du
lycée
je sais qu'aujourd'hui il y a les élèves
qui travaillent sur la shoah dans la
préparation précisément du concours de
la résistance la transmission la
connaissance le savoir
que rien ne soit laissé dans l'ombre
pire que rien ne puisse être interprété
la troisième réponse c'est de prendre
conscience que les thèses complotistes
prennent leur diffusion par internet et
les réseaux sociaux
or nous devons nous souvenir que c'est
d'abord par le verbe que s'est préparé
de l'extermination nous devons agir au
niveau européen et même internationale
pour qu un cadre juridique puisse être
définis et que les plateformes internet
qui gère les réseaux sociaux soient
mises devant leurs responsabilités
que des sanctions soient prononcées en
cas de manquement
l'union des anciens déportés l'union des
étudiants juifs de france
lance aujourd'hui même un appel contre
le négationnisme sur internet
il s'adresse aux grands opérateurs
nous les connaissons
ils ne peuvent plus fermer les yeux ou
alors ils seront considérés comme
complices de ceux qui se diffuse
la france soutiendra cet appel et cet
après midi je serai à auschwitz et je
demanderai aux représentants des
gouvernements qui sont présents de s'y
joindre également
à partir de ces principes
sécurité
transmission régulation du numérique je
souhaite que le gouvernement
présente d'ici la fin du mois de février
un plan global de lutte contre le
racisme et d'antisémitisme
le 11 janvier dernier
après ce qui s'était produit dans notre
pays
cet attentat sur trois jours qui a
touché des journalistes d'abord les
policiers ensuite des juifs enfin nous
étions des millions à témoigner que la
france se tenait droite face à ceux qui
voulaient la faire plier il avait des
dirigeants venus du monde entier qui a
testé avec nous que la france
lorsqu'elle était agressée était jamais
seul
notre réponse
ce fut la fierté
la dignité
et l'unité
nous sommes à proximité de l'allée des
justes qui longe ce mémorial est le son
des justes ce n'est pas simplement le
courage
c'est la lucidité
et c'est la responsabilité la dignité
toutes ces valeurs que la france a porté
le son des justes c'est qu'il existe
toujours une entrevoit que celle de
hurler avec la meute
ou de rester indifférent la leçon des
justes c'est que l'individu même seul
n'est pas sans pouvoir n'est pas sans
devoir
le message des justes il est beau il est
fort
ce sont les femmes et les hommes qui
font le monde tel qu'il est
et qui peuvent donc le changer
le son des justes c'est que la france
avance quand elle et rassembler autour
de ses valeurs
rassemblés
unis
n'empêche pas les différences elles sont
légitimes
n'écarte pas la diversité elle est
salutaire le débat démocratique
il est nécessaire mais au-delà de tout
il y à la république une et indivisible
alors à tous nos concitoyens à vous à
vous qui êtes les témoins je veux vous
dire que la france
protégera
protégera tous ses enfants qu'elle ne
tolérera aucune insulte aucun outrage
aucune profanation
ça vaut pour tous les cultes ça vaut
pour toutes les convictions toutes les
consciences je salue ici les
représentants de l'islam de france
qu'ils se joignent à nous des actes anti
musulmans se sont également multipliés
ces dernières semaines
et chaque fois que
une femme un homme un enfant est victime
d'une agression pour ce qu'il pense ou
ce qui ce à quoi ils croient c'est une
atteinte à ce que notre pays peut
représenter aux yeux du monde
ensemble nous sommes la france
celle de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen qui a proclamé à
la face du monde nul ne peut être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses
et la libre communication des pensées et
des opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme
les nations démocratiques
ont fait le choix d'inscrire le 27
janvier
dans la mémoire de l'humanité
compte elle voulu dire
que le 27 janvier c'est un événement
universel qui ne concerne pas que les
juifs
mais qui concerne le monde entier
une nation voulu aussi rappeler à tous
les peuples ou conduisait l'intolérance
et qu'elle pouvait les frapper tous
ces fraudes fans le philosophe
anticolonialiste y eut cette phrase
quand vous entendez dire du mal des
juifs
dresser l'oreille
on parle de vous
la mémoire des crimes contre l'humanité
n'appartient à personne
elle est notre héritage commun
pour comprendre la barbarie vous vous
l'avez vu en face
il faut savoir la reconnaître partout où
elle est et ceux qui prétendent nier une
souffrance
au nom d'une autre souffrance
ne sont jamais du côté des victimes
mais toujours avec les bourreaux
dans l'un des ses plus beaux livres
patrick modiano
le prix nobel de littérature
ce livre qu'il avait dédié à dora bruder
jeune fille disparue dans la nuit des
quand il écrivait ceci
il faut longtemps très longtemps
pour que ressurgisse à la lumière ce qui
a été effacé
c'est cette lumière que vous nous
redonner ici au mémorial vous les
anciens déportés vous les témoins vous
aussi des acteurs de la transmission et
c'est cette lumière que nous devons
porter tous ensemble contre les nuits
qui menace qui menacent encore qui
menacent ici qui menacent partout mais
nous sommes là vive la république et
vive la france
voilà pour ce discours de françois
hollande en direct du mémorial de la
shoah à l'occasion des 70 ans de la
libération du comptage est
contre la tyrannie
n'est pas dans
les classes a et b
30 ans de vos
héros sauna
là
allons
on
voilà 7 mars elle vient donc le fonds
purs ce discours de françois hollande
nous allons parler de ce discours avec
nos quatre invités qui sont nos quatre
invités qui sont toujours en plateau
avant de rentrer dans le détail de ce
discours un mot global michael un
discours un très fort de françois
hollande qui a fait quoi l'actualité
évidemment oui il a trouvé les mots pour
les mots et mahut x évidemment avec un
accent très prononcé sur la mémoire qui
pourra rester qui pourra expliquer après
quand les biens rencontre les déportés
seront repartis bien la république c'est
une promesse at il dit la république
n'oubliera jamais et puis des
interrogations bien évidemment
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui comment at
il pu ressurgir après tout ce qui s'est
passé il a voulu tout simplement essayé
de rassurer aussi cette communauté juive
la france c'est votre patrie vous êtes
ici chez vous vous êtes les enfants de
la france de tous pays ne serait plus la
france s'il devait vivre sans vous ça
fait un peu l'écho aussi à ce qu'avait
dit manuel valls à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale la france sont les
riches n'est plus la france et il ya eu
des annonces aussitôt été fan de la
république sur quatre points très
importants sur la sécurité sur la
transmission sur la sécurité par rapport
à internet il sera cet après-midi en
pologne à auschwitz pour les
commémorations il va demander à
l'ensemble des trente huit personnalités
politiques qui représenteront l'europe
et ne reste du monde de s'impliquer dans
la lutte contre le négationnisme qui
aujourd'hui déferle sur internet et puis
la demande et sur le plan plus
franco-français pour la fin février un
plan global de lutte contre le racisme
et de l'antisémitisme sur ces trois
points sécurité transmission et internet
il a rappelé les valeurs il a rappelé la
mémoire qui est très important
évidemment et puis l'art à parler de
l'islam l'ouverture qu'un jour dit ce
n'est pas seulement d'antisémitisme ce
n'est pas un conte en ouvrant le racisme
dans sa globalité on parle évidemment
non pas que des juifs car aujourd'hui
dans l'islam aussi évité par oeuvre ce
racisme qu un beau show avant de revenir
dans le détail des annonces de françois
hollande que retenez-vous de ce discours
l'émotion
l'engagement une promesse
extrêmement
forte
je retiens aussi
que ce ne sera pas facile d'y arriver
mais que c'est un impératif pour notre
démocratie
c'est un discours grave qui est
effectivement attendu avec des
références appuyées à badinter qui est
bien connu et reconnu à simone veil donc
pour aussi je pense incarner
7,7 choix et ce combat j'ai noté aussi
cette expression cendres et fumées qui
fait le pendant de ce marathon knoebel
nuit et brouillard en tout cas je le
vois comme cela et est effectivement au
delà de ce rappel historique de la
gravité de la situation la volonté de
dire ou aux juifs de france on vous aime
on a besoin de vous vous êtes ici chez
vous et on va essayer de se donner les
moyens de vous convaincre de rester
c'est la sécurité c'est la transmission
c'est la régulation effectivement ça a
été repris ces trois éléments là je suis
pas sûr que ça que ça suffise pour
apaiser tout le monde mais je crois que
ça va effectivement dans le bon sens et
je crois qu'il était aussi important il
l'a fait à deux reprises sauf erreur de
ma part de rappeler la responsabilité de
l'état français
je crois que on a des débats aujourd'hui
qui continue sur les responsabilités des
uns ou des autres mais le fait est que
il ya bien des juifs de france ou
étranger qui était réfugié en france qui
ont été à cause d'une politique de
collaboration
envoyé vers auschwitz ou ailleurs donc
que je crois que c'était important aussi
de de le rappeler et puis je trouve
important aussi d'élargir
le propos avec beaucoup de précaution
nous sommes bien au 70e le 27 janvier
mais assez génocide eux plus proche de
nous je pense au génocide tutsi j'ai été
un peu étonné d'ailleurs qu'il y fasse
référence
peut-être un peu moins sur la référence
au génocide arménien parce que nous
sommes aussi dans une période proche de
d'anniversaire on a des génocides de
nature sans doute un peu un peu un peu
différente mais j'ai noté j'apprécie ce
mouvement pour montrer que la france
reconnaît évidemment tout toutes ses
victimes sans vouloir faire d'un
amalgame parce que elles ont toutes bien
évidemment leur leurs spécificités donc
oui un grand un grand discours grave
solennel je crois qu'il ne donnera pas
lieu à contestation enfin je n'en vois
aucune je le dis très sincèrement juste
pour pour terminer je crois que c'était
important aussi de rappeler cet appel à
la dignité et à l'unité on est dans une
forme de continuité si je puis dire par
rapport aux événements des trois
dernières semaines
oui je le pense sincèrement d'abord dans
la gravité vous l'avez dit fort
justement dans la gravité au regard de
l'histoire mais dans la gravité au
regard des événements récents je crois
que le président de la république a
montré la queue et lui et le
gouvernement avait pris toute la mesure
de la situation actuelle et la gravité
de cette situation ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose je pense que
c'est la volonté politique affichée qui
est très qui me semble très importante
et qui au delà au delà de de la mémoire
de cette mémoire de la mémoire de cet
événement est une volonté politique bien
sûr qui vise à rassurer les français
juifs qui l'a rappelé la france et votre
pays vous êtes ici chez vous que c'est
quelque chose de très touchant de très
émouvant je pense que c'est une parole
que les français juifs attendent
nécessairement attendait
maintenant les mesures annoncées il
faudra il faudra bien voir comment elle
se met en place je pense qu'il faudra
aussi entamé des vraies réflexions sur
ma sur ces mesures vous savez
j'entendais le président et je l'entends
parfaitement il faut enseigner pouvoir
enseigner l'histoire de la shoah partout
c'est un point qui me semble extrêmement
important parce que vous savez on n'a
jamais autant enseigner l'histoire de la
shoah et je pense qu'on ne l'a jamais
aussi bien enseigner et parallèlement
nous n'avons jamais eu autant de
problème d'antisémitisme donc il va
falloir questionner cette réalité là
est-ce que rajouter l'enseignement de la
shoah
comment on leur ajoute est-ce que c'est
cela qu'il faut faire je pense qu'il ya
de vraies questions à se poser
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya de vrais
progrès à faire dans la conception de
l'enseignement et dans les questions que
l'on se pose on pourra si vous voulez en
parler plus en détail mon travail au
mémorial justement c'est cesser cela
n'occupe voilà je suis responsable des
formations mémoire de la shoah dont je
m'occupe de ces formations je réfléchis
beaucoup avec mon équipe sur la manière
dont on doit enseigner la shoah
l'histoire de la shoah et comment
justement faire passer faire passer cet
ce cas bien rappelé le président
l'universalité de cette question ce qui
me semble fondamental
peut-être peut-être un autre poids aussi
haut au delà de la de la transmission de
la mémoire parce qu'effectivement je
pense qu'on n'a jamais autant enseigner
la shoah ce qui s'est passé ces horreurs
avec toutes les difficultés le rejet
parfois mais il insiste et enfin il
insisté il est passé assez rapidement
sur sur un point et je crois que ça
devra faire aussi l'objet de mesures
peut-être un peu particulière en tout
cas en courant avec les jeunes peut être
d'une une approche spécifique s'est aidé
at il dit l'importation des conflits du
moyen-orient là on est plus dans la
transmission on n'est pas dans
l'histoire on est dans l'actualité et et
je crois que l'on doit avoir du coup une
réflexion sur plusieurs niveaux on a
bien sûr la transmission et vous avez
bien compris au travers de mes propos
aussi été particulièrement
attachez bien évidemment mais je crois
que ce serait une erreur de penser qu'on
peut se limiter à la transmission de
cette horreur et que l'horreur en
elle-même serait rédhibitoire et
repoussoir il faut faire attention à
cette importation des conflits du monde
du moyen-orient et il le président l'a
dit je crois que donkey 3 est passée
rapidement mais c'est un point qu'il
faudrait vraiment vraiment approfondir
parce que je crois que dans les dents
les mesures d'éducation il y à là
matière à vraie réflexion est donc un
travail avec les jeunes générations mais
pas seulement ça renvoie sans vouloir
tomber dans le cliché ça renvoie
finalement là aussi la perception des
différentes communautés si tenté que ce
terme est un sens chez nous en france
c'est toujours un vaste débat c'est la
place de l'islam c'est le choc frontal
des cultures et offenbach à la fin du
discours est il ouvre aussi de taper log
avec avec l'islam car je crois que c'est
important on est très important
aujourd'hui on veut parler vous parlez
de communautés de ce point
d'interrogation les de parler en tout
cas à ces deux familles oui on va rester
sur cette question de l'enseignement de
la shoah qui est une question très
importante et notamment ce que vous
disiez sur l'histoire des communautés
vous pensez que c'est peut-être plus par
la politique qu'il faut enseigner la
shoah et peut-être pas forcément par
cette évocation des souffrances dont
pareil si les gosses à une évocation
communautariste c'est à dire que moi je
suis bon j'ai une expérience de terrain
en seine saint denis depuis maintenant
17 ans et c'est à l'aune de cette
expérience que j'ai construit ma
réflexion sur cet enseignement et je
crois qu'il faut tenir compte des
réalités dans un monde idéal si vous
voulez montrer de la souffrance ça fait
pleurer tout le monde est bien d'accord
mais ça ne guérit pas ça ne guérit pas
et la chaux à auschwitz ce n'est pas un
médicament contre l'antisémitisme contre
le racisme la haine de l'autre je pense
que c'est très important de le dire il
faut effectivement
faire de l'histoire d'abord faire de
l'histoire c'est à dire que nous ne
devons pas nous avoir un discours quand
je dis nous ce sont essentiellement les
enseignants ne pas avoir un discours
moral moralisant si vous voulez du plus
jamais ça qui serait une injonction qui
n'a pas de sens si vous voulez pour
beaucoup d'élèves ça n'a pas de sens le
fameux devoir de mémoire cette
injonction à se souvenir à mon sens non
plus n'en a pas en revanche nous avons
un devoir d'éducation notamment
d'éducation politique et il me semble
très important de ne pas rentrer dans
cette histoire justement par la question
morale et la question de la souffrance
mais par la question politique or qui
mène la politique ce sont les nazis et
il faut rentrer dans cette histoire par
les bourreaux c'est à dire comprendre
comment ces gens concevait le monde
comment ils le voyaient quelle était la
place de l'antisémitisme dans cette
vision du monde et au delà quelle était
la considération qu'ils avaient pour
l'être humain en général et là vous êtes
dans une vision qui vise à
l'universalité vous êtes dans ce que
j'appelle moi la disqualification
malheureusement il faut parfois en
passer par là la disqualification du
nazisme et si vous disqualifier le
nazisme quelque part aussi vous
disqualifier l'antisémitisme qui en
forment la colonne vertébrale le
problème que nous avons et je crois et
je vais très clair là dessus c'est que
bon au delà du fait que ça fait des
années que j'essaie de peindre par les
pouvoirs publics n'ont rien à faire que
ça n'intéresse pas c'est très clair moi
je j'ai rencontré vincent peillon je
vais parler de ça appeler mon âme est
appelé mon cabinet et la personne ne m'a
jamais répondu donc c'est très
intéressant
quatorze fois j'ai appelé bien
aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il dans les
classes en troisième en classe de 3e les
élèves ont travaillé deux heures sur le
nazisme deux heures ce sont les
programmes les élèves qui vont au lycée
général vont travailler encore trois
quatre cinq heures dessus en fonction de
l'enseignant bien ce qu'ils vont en
lycée professionnel il ne revoit plus
jamais le nazisme c'est terminé vous
pensez qu'en deux heures ces gamins ont
pu acquérir des connaissances
suffisantes pour comprendre ce qu'a été
le nazisme pour comprendre pourquoi ils
ont mis en place la politique 10 est il
donc entre guillemets de solution finale
absolument pas il va falloir aussi que
les pouvoirs publics prennent leur
responsabilité je dirais les sens sans
être vindicatif les discours c'est très
important et ce discours et me semble
très fort il va falloir maintenant
mettre le doigt là où ça fait mal
c'est-à-dire dans les programmes
scolaires et la formation des
enseignants vous savez et je termine là
dessus les enseignants moi je passe mon
temps à former les enseignants sur ces
questions là je parcours la france et
même parfois l'europe mais pour ce qui
concerne notre pays
quand je forme les jeunes enseignants et
vous demander à une salle de 50 prof qui
a eu un cours de niveau universitaire
sur l'histoire de la shoah personne
personne c'est à dire que vous avez un
gap entre ce que l'on pense connaître
savoir évidemment l'événement shoah est
omniprésent n'est pas à l'école
dans les médias dans les représentations
et surtout pas à l'université il n'y a
pas de kourou par pratiquement pas de
l'histoire de la shoah à l'université ce
que savent les enseignants si vous
voulez correspond peu ou prou à ce que
connaît un téléspectateur assidu d'arte
et voilà
je voudrais poursuivre sur ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est une analyse à laquelle
j'adhère totalement et on a un paradoxe
c'est à dire que nous avons en france
des historiens de grande qualité qui
travaillent sur ces questions là je peux
pas les citer tous je vais en oublier
dans le désordre annette wieviorka
claire andrieu brutale man jean-marc
dreyfus qui vient de décrire encore un
livre remarquable nous avons si vous
voulez des intelligences universitaire
nous avons sur le terrain et c'est ça
qu'il faut voir des initiatives
intéressantes nous avons la possibilité
de former les enseignants maintenant les
sp ont été remises en place on a un
conseil supérieur sur les programmes qui
travaillent donc je dirais qu'on a la
possibilité de de bien faire maintenant
on a un souci et ça ça tient beaucoup à
notre notre histoire politique notre
rapport à ce qu elle universelle ce
qu'est le singulier nous sommes
réticents pour des raisons politiques
pour des raisons idéologiques à ce que
dans les universités
il est quelque chose qui fait polémique
en france et qui a été bien signalé
qu'ils seraient de l'ordre de ce qu'on
appellerait les shows à stony c'est à
dire une approche pluridisciplinaire où
vous auriez en même temps les académies
qui sont très spécialisés sur un sujet
sur un aspect de la choix et puis
regroupé je dirais les experts on les a
donc si vous voulez je pense que il faut
aussi je je le redis ce discours est un
discours fort politiquement il est très
pertinent mais il faut qu'il soit suivi
d'effets si on en reste uniquement à
quelque chose que l'on réclame et il
faut faire moi ce que je réclame si vous
voulez c'est que l'on parte de ce qui
existe sur le terrain et que l'on fasse
la jonction avec la mission dont il est
question sinon les discours ils seront
dans les livres d'histoire pour le coup
mais ils sont inopérants et on aura
toujours ce qui est quand même une
difficulté à savoir dans notre jeunesse
des publics qui passe à côté des progrès
de la recherche en histoire je vais
prendre un exemple et des efforts ont
été faits heureusement les jeunes qui
partent en apprentissage eh bien je
dirais quelques pas de parent souvent
leur origine familiale c'est ceux qui
ont le moins accès au savoir au film et
je dirais c'est ceux à qui on donne le
moins donc si vous voulez tant que dans
notre école en france je crois que c'est
ça le problème on a des enseignants de
bonne volonté la volonté politique elle
est là mais tant qu'on continuera pour
des raisons je vais me faire détester
mais parce que notre système fait que
quand vous avez le plus de points vous
allez dans les lycées de centre ville et
dans les beaux quartiers devant des
élèves qui ont déjà beaucoup et tant
qu'on continuera à envoyer les jeunes
enseignants sur le front en seine saint
denis dans les zones périphériques où
personne ne va qui vont essuyer les
plâtres à la fois de débuter dans le
métier est d'enseigner à des jeunes qui
sont peut-être les jeunes les plus
éloignés de savoir là tant qu'on sera
dans cette dualité là on ne s'en sortira
pas donc ce que dit ou ce qu'a dit le
président de la république ce matin et
moi c'est ce que je retiens c'est que si
vous voulez ce que dit cette résurgence
de l'antisémitisme se sont tous les maux
m à vix ça a été dit accumulés dans
notre société mais on ne pourra pas
uniquement les résoudre avec de la
répression et de la prévention
c'est bien c'est nécessaire et le
dernier point et c'est peut-être ce que
j'ajouterai nous devons fabriquer les
citoyens nous devons fabriquer des
citoyennes qui participent à la vie
publique est là pour le coup je vais me
faire mal voir par mes collègues mais
c'est aussi parfois l'image que nous
élus renvoyons à notre jeunesse
se trouve-t-il à s'incarner en où
trouve-t-il à s'incarner dans ce que
nous disons parfois malheureusement on
peut en douter et donc en fait ce
discours là me semble un discours tout à
fait fondateur est important mais si on
ne réussit pas moi je pense que c'est la
démocratie qui est en péril et je
voudrais dernièrement rappelé que les
jeunes ignorent peut-être c'est qu'on a
quand même et je ne veux pas dire son
nom mais un homme politique en france
très âgées qui a quand même réussi à
quelques années à dire que ce qu'on a vu
là ce qui s'est passé étaient un détail
de l'histoire si vous voulez à partir du
moment où vous avez un parti politique
il n'a pas pris ses distances avec cette
phrase là ou de façon extrêmement
organisés et qu'on voit dans un sondage
ce matin que 25% au départemental
d'intentions de vote vont à ce parti ce
parti qui peut être ne dirai pas ce que
nous sommes de façon assez oecuménique
en train de dire sur ce qu'on voit là je
pense que là notre démocratie elle est
en péril et je comprends que nos
concitoyens de différentes communautés
s'inquiète parce que je partage leur
inquiétude alors justement sur cette
inquiétude françois hollande a voulu
rassurer la communauté juive philippe
gosselin françois hollande qui a eu deux
phrases fortes la montée des actes
antisémites est une réalité
insupportable et il a dit aux juifs de
france vous êtes ici chez vous la france
et votre patrie c'était nécessaire que
françois hollande croit que c'est
important de le rappeler vous connaissez
les chiffres ou en tout cas en valais on
va lui rappeler plus de 7000 personnes
ont quitté la france pour s'installer
l'an dernier en israël donc et avec un
doublement en quelques années ce qui
interroge qui interpelle comme on dit on
est dans un pays la france où la
sécurité semble plutôt assuré je mets de
côté ce qui s'est passé il ya trois
semaines puisque les statistiques datent
d'avant pour aller dans un pays où il ya
des risques d'attentats dans la rue
c'est pas si simple et c'est donc vous
voyez à quel niveau on en est alors je
crois qu'il faut on aurait tort aussi de
réduire uniquement ce mouvement a à la
peur il ya aussi sans doute une
évolution
une interrogation qui se fait chez un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ont vite
donné aussi peut être un autre sens à
leur foi à leur vie que leurs parents
n'avaient pas nécessairement je crois
en france il faut effectivement faire ce
qui a été fait ces derniers jours
protéger mais ça ne peut durer qu'un
temps enfin je crois qu'on peut pas
vivre sous cloche en mettant pendant des
années et des années des années des
militaires devant tel ou tel
établissement ou synagogue enfin c'est
effectivement moi je comprends que ça
soit infernal pour les juifs qui peuvent
avoir l'impression d'être des citoyens
de seconde zone maintenant c'est une
mesure qui est nécessaire dans
l'immédiat je crois que l'éducation ça a
déjà été dit est un élément important
maintenant je souscris ce qui était dit
par corinne bouchoux sur l'intelligence
universitaire on a besoin de travaux
universitaires mais ce dont on a besoin
aussi donc je n'oppose pas là et l'autre
c'est une irrigation
d'une irrigation et on aurait tort de
penser que les phénomènes de rejet
l'antisémitisme ne se développe que dans
certaines banlieues où certains
départements je crois par capillarité il
ya aujourd'hui un peu plus de mouvement
maintenant on aurait tort aussi je veux
dit sincèrement je pense d'assimiler les
20 ou 25 % de français qui sont prêts à
voter fn que je ne suis pas les traiter
d'antisémite etc je pense que non mais
je dis bien mais je crois qu'il faudrait
se méfier de ce raccourci parce que il
ya sans doute des causes plus plus
complexe que cela donc en rejetant aussi
l'anathème ont fini par an créé les gens
dans un réflexe d'autoprotection donc je
crois qu'il faut faire très attention à
tout ça donc si on résume il y a bien
évidemment la transmission la mémoire il
ya la recherche qui doit jouer son rôle
la pédagogie est peut-être ne pas non
plus simplement se fixer les cours
d'histoire comme la porte ouverte pour
parler de ces événements
on peut très bien aux cours de français
choisir tel ou tel texte lorsqu'il
ambitions plus larges effectivement ça
veut dire que c'est une formation pas
simplement des enseignants d'histoire
voire de géographie mais aussi ceux de
français et pourquoi pas en langue enfin
on peut donc ça devient beaucoup plus
transversale
c'est je pense sur le long terme
beaucoup plus efficace mais c'est sans
doute beaucoup plus ambitieux parce que
ça pose la question des moyens c'est ce
que ce que ce que vous disiez et vous
n'avez pas être entendus ça pose la
question des moyens de la volonté un
peut-être peut-être avec ce 70e
peut-être avec les événements d'il ya
trois semaines at-on en france un
sursaut une unité pour que les
convergences enfin se fasse c'est ce que
l'on peut souhaiter et ce serait
évidemment on veut profitable vous
parlez aussi de ses 25% front national
évidemment ça repose aussi sur un
sentiment
beaucoup entendu parler entre nous sur
le plateau mais qui a été au feeling
rame un peu dit par le poteau de la
république c'est ce sentiment de peur ce
sentiment de peur il vient aussi parce
qu'on ne vit une crise qu'elle soit
économique ou sociétales on est dans une
période de crise qui renforce évidemment
ce sentiment vous parliez de ses
sentiments aussi deux de ces français
appartenant aux communautés juives qui
ont l'intention de partir ou même dans
la communauté musulmane on sent ce
malaise elle vient aussi de cette crise
très profonde crise économique qui
touche tout le tissu français à partir
du moment où il y aura peut-être moins
de crise il y aura peut-être moins peur
et on pourra commencer aussi à réparer
un petit peu ce qui ne va pas s'arrêter
c'est assez vraisemblable alors je crois
que on a au cours de l'histoire
différents liens qui ont été démontrés
entre confiance et développement
économique etc quand il ya pas de
tensions sur le marché du travail on
voit les uns ou les autres arrivés avec
une méfiance ou une approche très très
différentes et cetera et cetera
maintenant n'attendent en vélo mais bien
sûr mais elle n'est pas nouvelle mais
n'attendons pas je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord sur ce plateau n'attendons pas
un retour à meilleure fortune si je puis
dire en se disant tout s'arrangera par
le fait même temps je crois que la bête
est là il faut le dire moi je pense que
c'est le mot n'a pas été prononcé mais
il est et je pense en arrière-plan ce
dont notre société a besoin c'est d'une
vraie capacité de résilience et c'est
cette capacité de résilience
extraordinaires qui ont eu tous ces
témoins qui étaient là et je voulais
juste pour conclure moi rendre hommage
au terrain et je pense un professeur de
maine et loire qui s'appelle monsieur
jacobson qui depuis 20 ans emmène des
classes visité auschwitz et qui fait un
travail pédagogique remarquable et qui
peut-être gagnerait à être plus connu et
donc c'est aussi rendre hommage aux
soutiers qui travaille pour que cette
mémoire soient transmises via les radars
c'est à vous parvenir le mot de la fin
il nous reste 30 secondes françois
hollande a aussi eu des mots très forts
envers les survivants il a voulu leur
exprimer toute sa reconnaissance et la
gratitude de la nation et dire la
république franck
oui c'est important ce sont des gens
vous savez qui ont souffert dans leur
chair qui ont perdu des gens proches
oh les survivantes mis les aussi les
enfants de ceux qui sont morts les
petits enfants aujourd'hui et parfois
arrière petits enfants ces gens ont
besoin d'entendre que la république les
aime que la république que la france
c'est leur pays c'est extrêmement
important et je pense que ses mots ont
touché et les survivants et les
descendants de ceux qui ne sont pas
revenus merci beaucoup merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter ce discours de françois
hollande au mémorial de la shoah le
président de la république qui se rendra
cet après midi à auschwitz pour la
commémoration officielle merci aussi de
nous avons rappelé l'importance de la
transmission et de ne jamais cesser de
parler de ce qui s'est passé pour ne
surtout pas oublier merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi et à très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires